[Música]
el momento de hablar de noticias
relacionadas con la economía qué tal
estuvo la jornada de hoy se lo vamos a
preguntar a jorge hurtado de la
redacción económica de france 24
hablamos entonces jorge buenas noches
bienvenidos del mercado bursátil a nivel
global cerró en terreno negativo que
pasó bueno un día bastante negro oscuro
para las bolsas bursátiles del mundo
cerró wall street' con su mayor caída en
dos meses con los inversores preocupados
sobre todo por la posibilidad de que la
reserva federal de eeuu continúe con su
agresiva política de subida de los tipos
de interés y por el efecto que esto
pueda tener en la economía sobre todo
los temores de una recesión ahora se
espera con especial atención los
comentarios que hará este viernes el
presidente de la fed gran power durante
un simposio económico en wyoming eeuu
mientras en europa las acciones también
cayeron a su nivel más bajo en casi un
mes esto por la preocupación de nuevas
limitaciones del suministro de gas por
parte de rusia así como las señales
restrictivas del banco central europeo y
las débiles perspectivas económicas en
américa latina' el índice ibovespa
principal referente de la bolsa de sao
paulo abrió la semana en números rojos
porque cambios internos y el pesimismo
del resto de los mercados
internacionales vamos ahora a hablar del
sector automotriz es la compañía ford
que es estadounidense anunció que va a
eliminar esta semana tres mil puestos de
trabajo en sus plantas de eeuu de canadá
e india porque santiago así lo comunicó
bill ford y su consejero delegado jim
farley según varios reportes los
despidos hacen parte de la
reestructuración de la compañía
denominada ford plus hasta finales de
2021 por empleaba en todo el mundo a 186
mil 769 de personas de las que casi la
mitad más de 90 mil trabajan en centros
situados en eeuu este anuncio se produce
cuando muchas compañías buscan reducir
costos ante el rápido aumento de la
inflación y el temor de que se produzca
una recesión económica en el mundo jorge
pese a que la economía ya está un poco
más abierta después de los
confinamientos que dejaron la pandemia
de kobe 19 estamos todavía conociendo el
impacto económico que tuvo la pandemia
bueno hay una actualización de estas
cifras y sobre todo en reino unido que
registró en 2020 suma caída de la
producción en más de 300 años según la
oficina de estadísticas nacionales el
producto interno bruto cayó un 11 por
ciento en 2020 se trata de la mayor
caída desde mil 709 según los datos
históricos del banco de inglaterra el
daño fue especialmente grave en el
segundo trimestre cuando el gobierno
impuso las restricciones más severas
para evitar contagios por el cob y 19 la
oficina advirtió que no se debían hacer
comparaciones directas con otros países
ya que la mayoría a excepción de eeuu
aún no hacen el mismo tipo de revisiones
a profundidad y pasamos ahora a hablar
de las sanciones impuestas a rusia
afectan particularmente a los oligarcas
y afectan sus bolsillos bueno hablamos
de la puesta en subasta de un yate del
empresario ruso dmitry polyansky que se
venderá en subasta este martes esto
luego de que el multimillonario no
pudiera devolver un préstamo a chip y
morgan este sería el primer super yate
que se subasta públicamente desde que
inició la invasión rusa en ucrania el
axioma como se llama fue incautado en
gibraltar en marzo por las autoridades
del mar mediterráneo el barco está
valorado en 63 millones de libras aunque
se espera que se venda por debajo de ese
precio jeep y morgan obtuvo una orden
judicial que permitiría la venta del
buque de 73 metros luego de que el
empresario renegara de un préstamo de 20
6 millones de dólares y que está
precisamente vinculado a este barco
hablemos ahora de el ex presidente y
actual candidato otra vez a la
presidencia de brasil luiz inácio lula
da silva quien me habló de la
posibilidad de reabrir las negociaciones
entre el mercosur y la unión europea
todo de cara a ese posible tlc bueno
según el candidato izquierdista este
acuerdo no es válido y debe ser
renegociado lula argumenta que el
tratado de 2019 no es válido porque no
fue concretizado plenamente y todavía no
fue ratificado por los países firmantes
el acuerdo comercial comercial entre
mercosur y la unión europea europea fue
suscrito en 2019 tras más de dos décadas
de conversaciones durante la gestión del
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro que
precisamente ahora es su rival en las
elecciones de octubre la creciente
preocupación los europeos por la
seguridad de su abastecimiento
energético de materias primas hacen que
este proyecto vuelva a ponerse sobre la
mesa en bruselas y también en berlín y
para el cierre hablamos de la inflación
en méxico que pasa cultura a un producto
muy emblemático y que sirve para es
pulso para ver cómo está la economía la
tortilla bueno hablamos de la inflación
más alta desde el año 2000 que está
afectando el precio de este producto
básico de la dieta mexicana sobre todo
en el norteño estado de sonora donde el
kilo llega a venderse en 30 pesos o 15
dólares el precio más alto del país
aunque la procuraduría federal del
consumidor afirma que el costo promedio
del kilo de tortilla en sonora es de 21
pesos o 108 dólares en los puestos
populares el precio es mucho mayor la
tortilla de maíz ha sido uno de los
productos más afectados por la inflación
que alcanzó a un nivel general de 8,15
por ciento en julio estamos hablando de
la cifra anual pero entre enero de 2021
y junio de 2022 hablemos del precio de
la tortilla se disparó un 26 como 45 por
ciento según el índice de precios
consumidor
muchas gracias jorge es todo por el
momento en la economía aquí en directo
américa a continuación el debate
[Música]